impeccablement et toi massa a quitté nos
amis bvg par des membres en perte à lui
un héritage c'est qu'on imaginait un
porte-clés c'est le rapporte clé c'est
un talisman ce talisman permet de se
balader dans les dimensions alternative
de notre réalité
[Musique]
bon
je vous ai dit de parler moins fort mais
qu'est ce que vous faites avec ses
vêtements
vous n'avez aucun respect attend lui
qu'il a pensé à quoi la dimension où il
est interdit d'être un pilote en libye
ne structure pas alors la position du
chakra zana anus
on lève la jambe gauche comme ça bon
messieurs c'est soit tout nu soit d'or
obama dehors du coin on va le qui fait
quoi là c'est vous dire que genre là on
pourrait dans une dimension je sais pas
moi par exemple ou la roux n'a jamais
existé ouais à temps j'essaye voilà
non
[Musique]
fake buck maman aujourd'hui j'avais
nouvelle figure à l'école regard ça
s'appelle la
attends attends vaste et moi c'est moi
toi tu m as un mec témoin et si la ferme
au [ __ ] tu as la tête des lycées
boudent toi aussi
évidemment qu'il a la tête des lycées
mon jeu tout le monde à la tête des
lycées mon ici depuis toujours plus que
vous voulez qu'ils aient la tête de kim
maman dont je veux un poney hors de
question et reviens tu as déjà huit
chiens allez on rentre ok ok pas
bienvenue dans la dimension où paris est
au mexique présent mais il ya carrément
rien oui on au milieu du parc que paris
et au mexique au futur où les favelas
quelqu'un jyske été attrapés à moisie
d'ici une dimension où la douleur est un
plaisir
les tétons là où vous dites sur moi je
prends mon pied la magie continue à ok
une dimension où tout le monde est
télépathe attend une dimension où la
télé c'est des pâtes évasive ah bah ça
marche avec tous tes pattes une
dimension où la fibre n'existe pas tu
mets différents soit non une dimension
ou youtube n'existe pas je me demande ce
que fait ibra tv de sa vie du coup
astrophysiciens a pas d'accord ok ok à
mon tour une dimension où on ce rennais
vingt ans plus tard donc ça c'est le
futur
molas casse je veux dire une connerie là
mais tête il existe par l'espace temps
changent pas quoi là une dimension tout
me réussit tu vois où tout concorde ou
subi aucun échec et aux yeux de tout le
monde je suis une sorte de perfection
incarnée
[Musique]
m
il a visé
on dira qu'elles ont été dessinés par
dieu lui-même
regardez ses cernes elles ont l'air si
douce si moelleuse maman tu me mets même
t-shirt le monsieur moi aussi sonia
monsieur c'est le plus beau des t-shirts
moisséens tribord donc je voulais change
contre ma fille
arrêtez moi je suis personne mois les
personnes écoutez le c'est un exemple
d'humilité pour nous tous à clermont le
personnes personnes qui vont petits
poteaux vous avez bien des photos
fonctionnement mais des ebooks carrément
peu trop quoi et ça va me toucher moi et
mon rôle est bien sûr en chair et en os
pour cent mille pages et écouler les
quiches ou de l'homme
goulet a plu nathan on devrait rentrer
[Applaudissements]
ok ça va être compliqué
[Musique]